[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what's up the keys it is Monday morning
earlier start here at thick boy Studios
kicking off with barely finished my
coffee and I come straight to the studio
we got three shows today back to back to
back we got this we gotta find the kid
and then we have a food truck diary with
us very special guests so we in it baby
we are in it so get that morning pop
from your boy right now morning puff in
the face look like a Sharpay right now
in the morning so it is what it is man
we had some good fights over the weekend
shout out to Ontario uh improv the
Inland Empire doing the damn thing it's
not close out there in Inland Empire
Ontario you think you look at it's like
60 miles that is not gross it is pretty
far
you didn't go out there right you know
you didn't go no uh Stevie blue eyes
came out oh nice did you win cat or no
what no this cat was out of town so he
was able to do his thing but man it is
it's tough out there man
just to get out there like oh it doesn't
look far and then there's not even
accidents it's just like I mean you look
at two and a half three hours no matter
what that's crazy every time no matter
what we stayed at Airbnb because it was
such a beast and uh there's just donkeys
everywhere we just had donkeys so you
actually stayed there all weekend well I
yeah we did and then Saturday I drove
down because tiger had his first soccer
game but I was like I won't be bad it's
Saturday morning I'll leave at 8 A.M
wrong son two hours it just it just it
is what it is up there is there anything
to do out there uh we hung out this cool
Mall
great crowds you know there's a huge
NASCAR out there like there's a giant
NASCAR track out there really yeah I
don't know man I don't know shout out to
uh Inland Empire but uh yeah man you had
some uh fights over the weekends you
know
not the most exciting uh all all-out
gangbuster uh fights you know in the
main event for the UFC fighting at you
my boy Corey the Sandman Santa Hagin for
song Young dung and then you also had
the probably the biggest fight over the
weekend was Triple G Canelo you know
none of them are going to be fight of
the year
um if you want to kick off Canelo Triple
G
to me you know when a guy's fight in a
Trilogy fight you know this is they've
had before going into this fight they've
had 24 rounds together so I figured this
was gonna be the one this is gonna be a
classic there's no there's not gonna be
a feeling out process you know they're
gonna kind of let you know just their
hands go because they know each other
you know
um but that was not the case it was
Triple G just didn't take any chances
really to what the ninth tenth round he
finally started getting going but then
it was a little way too late man way too
late not the most exciting fight Canelo
definitely uh followed times on his side
had a huge speed Advantage again I don't
know what the you know boxing we know
this is very corrupt
and Yuji Canelo being as big as a name
as he is and remember in the first fight
a lot of people think Triple G won that
fight and I think it was a draw that
probably should have went to
um Triple G but
um usually when you're that big of a
name you have the judges in your pocket
but barely not Saturday night because
they gave Triple G like the the 1 15 to
113. come on what are we watching
you know what I'm saying under the one
the 116 112 is insane 115 113 even is a
little dicey man but uh
I mean I'm with Kevin aioli I love Kevin
aioli uh so he says Alvarez 10 to 9 in
the 12th and wins by shutout 120 108 the
embracing Center Rings tweaked each
other so Kevin and I already had him
winning he basically yeah wins by
shutout 120 to 108. I would give Triple
G
maybe two rounds if I'm being cool and I
like Triple G but Triple G is a goddamn
Legend Triple G is a g no pun intended
because you look at the people he's lost
to just Canelo and one of them he didn't
you know
Legend dude but I really father time
really caught up on the speed the
technique of Canelo kind of won that
thing
um a lot of people I mean not my house
so you know my girls from Guadalajara
they freaking would drink canelo's bath
water if they could and make a freaking
you know cortada with it but um in the
Green Room everyone's going for Triple G
I think because he's older you know you
don't want to see a guy go out like that
but I was like what even my photographer
sees her he's great he's from Mexico he
was going for triple Jessica you're out
of your mind dude are you communist
can't be from Mexico and rude against
Canelo you're out of your [ __ ] mind
but he's like I don't know it's a triple
G's older would be cool he kind of get
[ __ ] over I'm like I get it for it but
for boxing like Triple G you know he's
on he's on his he's on the 18th hole of
his career like canelo's probably you
know can I was not young in the tooth
but
for boxing you definitely need canola to
win that thing for the momentum keep
going and also Canelo he's going he
wants to go back up and fight homeboy
who he lost to which I think is a and it
just shows you the heart of canel he's
like the last true Mexican boxer who
will fight anybody just goes forward
he's a Savage he's the last of that kind
man so hopefully there's some young buck
coming up that wants to do that from
Mexico but Canelo is an actual Mexican
dude he's a Savage but for Triple G yeah
I don't know
see I will beat him some of the people
it's a nightmare matchup for him but if
he beats him hats off to him you know
uh but again the fight you know and also
even usually I'm like you know I want to
make sure the fighters get paid stuff
like that so when you see the UFC
pay-per-view I'm never like no way man
this is too I'll never like grunt about
like oh this is too much because I know
it's going to some somewhat of the
Fighter's Pockets by someone I mean like
point five percent but still at least
they're getting paid with box and when
it when you look at that thing said I
think 86.99 like God that's kind of like
the 86 number is 99 you're like holy
[ __ ] boxing it just shows you like even
the fight night compared to this huge
you know boxing card like the UFC just
puts on such a better show like from the
production value obviously it's the Zone
who's a bit of a nightmare but just the
the layoff between the co-main event and
the main event you're like waiting
around and there's like an hour before
they even walked out who has this time
dude let's get going here man the hell
are we doing
um and it's funny too because a lot of
people like I I think even you mentioned
on Monday train you're like you know
canel Triple G fights this weekend I
think for like if you're not like balls
deep in box and it was a little
surprising because against the Zone
they're not the best at marketing they
just don't have that like marketing
machine like the UFC or Showtime does
but
for Mexicans I mean they start this
thing on their counter because he fights
twice a year this Cinco de Mayo and he
fights on the Independence Day it's
really what he does so they knew what
was going on listen Inland Empire knew
what the hell you know a lot of Latins
out there they because everyone's like
oh the marking it's not like they you
know
um put this out much it seems like this
one's kind of quiet like it's not though
dude it's definitely not it's it's a
[ __ ] national holiday in Mexico and
he fights and he fights the same time of
year my girl was in freaking Vegas for
this and the senior I don't know his
name my Mexican fans are going to kill
me the singer whose dad who's like the
most famous Mexican singer of all time
his son is the one that sang when
canelo's walking out so micro is at his
concert his concert was the same time as
canelo's fight like the main event this
dude ran from his Arena over to that
Arena walked out with Canelo singing
My Girls concerts packed waiting for
this dude to come out with his chops
right he has these long chops so he
sings does his thing runs back doesn't
start the concert till after the fight
was in the green and watching the fight
hey dude keep going here man so everyone
in my girls into a huge Arena everyone's
on their phones watching Canelo fight
he's back there watching Canelo fight
they could just space him out a little
bit maybe doing a Friday night dude what
are we doing here man but
that uh yeah I thought we had this comic
with us who you know he doesn't know
fighting he's like so are they gonna
fight a fourth time I'm like absolutely
not sir fighting doesn't work like that
I mean you three and then there's a you
know there's no it's very rare there's a
fourth fight the the rubber like when
you do the trilogy stuff it's it dude
nobody's trying to see this the fourth
fifth time it's very rare so yeah no
this is over Dude Canelo won what you
know two out of three one was a draw you
know but a lot of people think the fans
probably think Triple G won that draw so
you know still two to one kill all this
thing's over but both Legends man the
next big thing in boxing is going to be
Crawford and um
yep that would be the big one and then
uh little uh rumors coming out of the UK
not only did the queen die which is
obviously the big deal over there but
the the next big news besides the queen
dying is Joshua versus Tyson Fury son
and I don't give a [ __ ] that Anthony
Joshua's lost two fights to USIC Joshua
Fury I have to see before I pass away
that is going to be the biggest fight in
the UK history man it's gonna be massive
now it would be I mean it would be
internationally I would say probably
biggest fight of all time if Joshua was
also undefeated he he could lose to
homeboy Andy Reeves and come back if he
was on a winning streak now if he would
beat usig this fight would be so [ __ ]
big but you know it hasn't gone that way
it's gonna be a tough fight for Joshua
but man what a chance for Joshua to
completely redeem himself man he's been
he's been on the outs right now he beats
Fury I don't think he will but if he
does what here we go
let's take a little break from me
chatting your ear off about the fight
game Boston next week Thursday Friday
Saturday Boston laugh Boston I am coming
Boston let's do this listen it is The
Fall season kids welcome to fresh ball
fall it's the season of pumpkin spice
everybody loves them little lattes
especially them hoes and making sure
your crotch looks nice that means
sipping cider in a fall Breeze and using
manscape products to trim your balls
with ease that's right today's show the
shop show is brought to you by manscape
the company here to make sure that your
foliage isn't the only thing shedding
its excess leaves heck even Mother
Nature knows it's time to lose excess
clutter for the fall so what are you
doing fellas yup Bros you got them
bushes out there what you doing man
nobody wants that it's not the 60s
anymore seen some old 70s porno join the
6 million Bros worldwide who trust man
escaped by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with the code shop
20 SCH ab20 whether you're brand new or
already with the boys at manscape you
could use the crown jewel of care for
your family jewels I'm talking about the
Platinum package 4.0 that's right man
you get this package you cover your
freaking hygiene all in one swoop baby
inside this 10 part Platinum package you
hit the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer weed
whack nose ear hair trimmer all right
you get the skin safe technology to
protect those delicate parts right and
all those holes surrounding it both are
waterproof so you can keep escaping even
as the weather's changing do it in the
rain shave your nuts in the rain dude
get weird with it in addition to shaving
can now completely upgrade your shower
routine with the ultimate premium body
wash and Ultra Premium two in one
shampoo conditioner you have your skin
here feeling hydrated and smelling like
a freaking dandelion don't forget to
apply their aluminum Free Ultra Premium
deodorant all right and also they get
the crop Preserve server ball deodorant
all right it's a crop reviver ball toner
to make sure you get to smell
so nice all right manscaped even through
in two free gifts into this Platinum
package the manscape boxers and shed
travel bag all right so it can hold all
your goodies get the Platinum packages
fall these products are guaranteed to be
hits for your dangly bits go to
manscape.com get twin soft and free
shipping with code shop20 that's 20
South with free shipping at manscape.com
when you use the code shop20 schab20
manscape play out the leaves it's your
tree trunks time to shine let's get back
to the program psych not back to the
program because I want you guys to watch
football NFL football the action is hot
my Broncos got the win but they're not
looking great my rate my Rams aren't
looking that great either the Chargers
lost to the Chiefs your boys losing
money don't be like me make smarter bets
quit being so biased right but do it
with my friends at DraftKings one of the
official sports betting partners of the
NFL we're talking touchdowns big plays
even bigger wins new customers can bet
just five dollars on any NFL team to win
and get 200 in free bets if you do if
that's not enough for you cool man
everyone can boost their winnings with
the DraftKings stepped up same game
parlays that's why my degenerate uh
producer Nick was able to do a six-man
parlay uh with DraftKings for the fight
night this past Saturday he bet 35 won
two thousand dollar rules
yeah right now for every leg you add you
can boost your winnings up to 100 with
payouts bigger than ever why bet on
football anywhere else man what are you
doing it's only DraftKings if you ain't
using DraftKings you ain't she to make
things even sweeter you can throw down
on stepped up same game parlays once per
game day all season long download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app right now use
promo code shop show that's Schaub show
to get 200 in free bets if your team
wins when you place that Five Dollar Bet
on any football game that's coach shop
show only at draftking Sportsbook an
official Sportsman part of the NFL
minimum age eligible restriction Supply
C show notes for details see next page
for directions for disclaimer download
DraftKings Sportsbook app now use promo
code shop show and then if you go to the
UFC fight night again nothing to blow
your hair back uh God our boy Nick did
some crazy like five fight parley sent
it to me dude he bet I think six hundred
dollars on like six thousand dollars
a degenerate Gambler so he probably lost
six thousand dollars by the end of the
card on fighting or you know on NFL but
still he's like yeah baby it's like oh
man it's just random like parlays man he
does his homework though he really does
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that dude he
knows this [ __ ] like let me look at what
he sent me it I mean I don't know
anybody who would do this but sorry but
he goes [ __ ] yes so he it's a parlay
first of all no he's a parley but it's a
one two three four five six six fight
parlay
34 so I was a little off 34 dollars to
win
2154 he bet 34 on the six flight parlay
six fight parlay is [ __ ] unheard of
it's tough enough to do a three-man
parley so he took uh Daniel zellhuber
over Trey Ogden over two and a half
rounds he took Denise go uh yeah Denise
Gomes over two and a half uh rounds
Trevin dials over one and a half rounds
Damon Jackson under two and a half Ian
Hernandez wins inside the distance and
then Tanner Bowser minus 170. I mean you
got to be a complete degenerative you
ever heard of half these guys I just
mentioned and this dude just throwing
change at it 34 dude you know you got a
gambling problem when you're betting 34
dollars to win two thousand you know
what I'm saying you got problems then
you got [ __ ] problem stick but you
pulled it off dude dicks rich rich hate
me throwing some crazy bets Nick's he's
such a degenerative gamer he'll be like
man can you believe I got robbed on that
Cameron Van Camp Nicholas Moana fight
I'm like who he's like dude come on dude
it's the first prelim on the UFC Fight
Night in Vegas man oh no I didn't I
didn't bet I didn't see the lines on
that one I didn't know they have lines
for everybody but uh yeah overall you
know there's some uh good finishes but
overall you know you gotta take your hat
off to my boy Corey Santa Hagen Aurora's
finest baby he looked like a goddamn
Savage and I loved his demeanor uh as
they were introducing the fighters some
young dong is a little more laid back
that's more his style right he trains
with Team Alpha Male but Corey Santa
Hagin was just lasered focused and
remember he's coming off with two fights
losing streak and now he did lose to the
upper echelon you're talking about Peter
yawn you lost TJ Dillashaw so he's he
lost to the very very best we have to
offer but still for a guy like him to be
on a two-fight losing streak he hasn't
won since October of 2021 for him man if
you know I'm sorry he hasn't won since
February of 2021. his last fight was uh
October 30th 2021. so he even had a win
inside that akian in since February of
2021 when he beat Frank Yeager and got
performed to the night uh of that over
invokoff card yeah so then he goes on to
you know TJ Del shall lose Split
Decision Jen thinks he won that fight I
definitely don't and I absolutely love
both those guys I don't
um then loses Peter yon right for the
interim Championship so that next fight
they didn't do him any favors get him
some young dung sung young dong is also
on ESPN and most hardcores lists I think
they have them as the number one Fighter
for uh 25 years and under so he's a
Young Savage man so
I wasn't crazy about this fight for
Corey sandagen now I don't think song
Young dong loses any
um momentum because he's never fought a
top 10 guy sure as [ __ ] number five
top five guy going into that fifth round
I had it pretty even and the judge's
scorecards came out they also had it
pretty even going to that fight too so
um you know it shows you that that sun
young dong is the real deal man I I
would I I always say this when guy when
guys are savages and they lose a fight
like this I feel sorry for he has to
fight next because he's he's right up
there man he's a top seven Talent man
he's right there and he's 24. 24 years
old man punches like a goddamn Savage
dude you know so for Corey sanderhagen
it was so important to get a win here
and get his name and and also stay you
know at the at the top there stay in the
top four there I think they have them as
three is that right tune so ranked
number three
so he's four they put um Rob uh over him
Rob and he called out marab after the
fight
which just shows you the confidence and
uh what a sociopath Corey Santa Higgin
is because name one other fighter who
called out marab ever ever he's the
boogeyman he's just this wrestler he
obviously just beat Jose Aldo
I could see them doing the Court Santa
taking marab fight
um
ah
it's tough because the the the fighters
that I'm closest to in that division are
TJ Dillashaw Corey sandahagan and Marlon
via Cheeto I'm I'm you know I'm close
with all of course I've known since he
was a kid same gym same Hometown I love
that kid uh TJ Del Shaw very close
friend and then Cheeto very close friend
right so
um
I would prefer because I'm biased Corey
fights maram and that's fight that he
asked for and they got to figure out
what they're gonna do with Rob but
there's the division right now it's so
stacked it's so fun to be a fan right
now with uh the divisions this just
dance with talent and Superstars so
especially for this division
um
you know
I think what would be the most exciting
fight would be Cheeto versus uh Corey
sandhagen that's a great [ __ ] fight
dude that's a phenomenal fight but for
Cheeto he's coming off Big Win dude you
freaking Kick The Omelette Cruz in the
face like that knockout you know so he's
had some big wins so part of me wants
Marlon uh Cheeto to get you know the
next title shot but it's all predicated
on the you know Peter yon Suga Al
Jermaine TJ then yep murab there Murad
phenomenal fighter Savage but also in
predominantly wrestling so he's not the
most exciting guy but but if you want
straight excitement Cheeto Corey
sandahagan that should be co-main event
on a pay-per-view you could do it as a
main event on Fight Night it does need
to be five rounds so
um if that means it's a fight night it
does need to be five rounds I don't want
that thing to be three I need five
because my boy cheating is a little bit
of a slow starter Corey comes out like
you [ __ ] Banshee sometimes so five
rounds out of that and then Jose Aldo
I'm sure you have it in the current
events chin uh retired so the number six
guy in the world's pulling out shout out
to Jose Aldo the king of the [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying the king dude of
that division the king man one of the
absolute best
the thing what's interesting about when
you look at Jose Otto's career and he
had this late Surge and I think
retirement's probably the best move
because
for him to get back to to you know he's
a guy who fights for championships and
you know he lost he had a rough patch
from 2019 220 last three in a row right
he lost a volkanovsky enough to hang
your head about Marlon Marias and then
Peter Yan
um you know so then he goes on this
three fight win streak he beats Cheeto
Pedro Munoz Rob font like oh [ __ ] and
his team really [ __ ] up taking that
Murad fight he could have waited and you
know this was his last goal man you know
this was the finale and then you toss
him in there was marab character who's
just a nightmare of a match-up form
where he could have waited probably got
a title shot they would have sent him
off the right way I much prefer Jose
Aldo to fight for the title and then
retire but now it's like it's kind of
sad like he lost him around take down
wasn't that exciting a fight marob just
did his thing all right so
you know I don't know what he's going to
do so it's it says I don't see him
negotiate a release from his UFC
contract with one bout remaining
interesting meaning that he's free to
pursue an uh discuss the move to a box
and other combat sport opportunities
yeah you know I know obviously the the
trendy thing to do is you go over to
boxing get these big super fights but
who the [ __ ] at that weight class is
gonna fight Jose Aldo no YouTubers sign
up to fight [ __ ] Jose Aldo you know
there's not really any big names you
know that these not a big crossover for
him to pursue boxing
um dude you want to talk about a guy
he's [ __ ] in Brazil and I've been
around him in Rio he's Tom [ __ ] Cruz
in Brazil you know they do have their
superstars in the Hollywood superstars
in their hip-hop artists and [ __ ] like
that and singers but the fighters there
they're Michael Jordan in Chicago big
knock little knock Shogun vanderlay
those guys man the Glover who's the
champ Jose Aldo dude they are [ __ ]
Superstars man they're the way the
fighters here should be treated you know
the way Connor was treated in his in his
absolute prime in like Europe that's the
way even guys who you know were on
losing skids like that like even Bigfoot
Silva Superstar even though he's lost I
don't know 70 fights in a row whatever
the [ __ ] he's on but he they're treated
the way they should be treated out there
it's fantastic but shout out to Joe's
Allen he's a smart guy too he has his
restaurants he has a I know he's a
burger chain like he's a he's a big deal
man so shout out to him one of the
greatest to ever [ __ ] do it again
he's a guy WC Legend right UFC Legend
and then really he flew under the radar
he didn't get the recognition he
deserved until he had an adversary and
Conor McGregor and the one Tim and
Connor started going at it that just
built also the legend of Kana but also
built up the profile of Jose Aldo
because you had a the Batman and Joker
thing that's what people love you know
with Jon Jones you had the DC Jon Jones
you had Batman Joker good guy bad guy
the fans love that stuff they love that
hostility and unfortunately even though
he got starts in that fight and I wish
they would have done a rematch but for a
million reasons we would never see that
again Connor you know
put a lot of weight him finding out the
45 is never happening again so
um you know I it's just for Jose Aldo he
for him to go out the way he did in the
Rob fights kind of a bummer but still at
least he went out you know winning three
I was last four you know three hours
last four baby so shout out to one of
the greatest ever dude if not the
greatest ever doing that division but
for Corey Santa hey I know he called out
murab just shows you what a Savage is
and a lot of people
are like man I didn't realize Corey
could switch that much with his footwork
and you know his his game plan with the
takedowns and he alluded to it in the
post-fight press conference where he
goes we just wanted to wear him out so
they didn't care about the success of
the takedown all they want to do is have
sung young
hesitate real hesitant to throw because
he's a really good box and punches like
a [ __ ] Savage so all they want to do
is slow him down a beat so Corey Santa
he can get off some other stuff so you
can't just let something fire off he's
too powerful so it was brilliant
brilliant strategic
um game plan there and you know him and
the way he's moving people like oh it's
very TJ dillshaw it's very Dominic Cruz
you guys are missing one thing there now
this guy's not as famous as Dominic Cruz
who's obviously the originator of that
and even his Style's a little different
but the originator of uh a lot of this
stuff is a guy named Christian Allen
who's my first coach ever Christian
Allen we call him the ninja and he's The
Mastermind behind Corey sanderhagen and
Corey Sandy and Corey sandahagan has
been with Christian Allen
since he was 16 years old and Christian
Allen who is the most talented guy
you've ever seen in the gym he's black
belt and Jiu Jitsu Black Mountain
[ __ ] Taekwondo name of martial art
he's a black belt it he and when he was
on the show he I don't know if he
appeared on camera but we've had Corey
in here I think two or three times but
um Christian Allen
um was a guy who there there he is
so he came up with me and with Shane and
Trevor and Dwayne Ludwig and he's just a
savant when it comes to fighting and
when he was fighting he was always it
was just almost like uh the lights were
too bright he was more of a practice guy
but when uh in the training room he was
such a [ __ ] Savage and if you could
just get that you know if you could just
kind of get his talent and make it count
inside the UFC you have a world champion
and that's Corey sandahagan Corey will
be your Champion even though he's 30
he's he's a young 30 man he's a young 30
he's a [ __ ] Savage so you know Chris
Young has download and poured every inch
of his talent and His Brilliant mind
into Corey sandyhagen that's why Corey's
such a [ __ ] Savage so a lot of people
with credit Dominic Cruz or TJ Dillashaw
or you know some of these other guys
that move like Diamond Cruz but that
movement has been
created through Christian Allen Dominic
who's just the most famous guy do it and
it's not very it's not a dominant Cruise
style movement but it looks like that to
the untrained eye it's a Christian Allen
movement that's what Corey Santa hagin's
doing
um and you know he's Savage you look
phenomenal that that that game plan was
great now that being said you know that
was an even fight man I had it 2-2 going
going into that fifth round and even
Corey goes man he deserved the fifth
round you know but that cut was bad man
it was bad because in song Young dong
let you know that the the
doctor made the right decision I thought
they could have stopped it earlier
um but they made the right decision she
was sung young dong alluded to Corey
sandhagen while they're still knocked on
goes though I couldn't see out of my
eyes the blood was going I couldn't see
anything dude so like oh yeah this
should definitely that's exactly why
you'd stop the fight and also the blood
obviously the blood run of the eye is
concerned but the cut that cut was so
bad it crossed uh you know multiple
different regions of the muscle across
the face which is that's the problem
yeah and that's Corey's elbows man that
up elbow he's a Savage that cuts bad man
so it's not that you know the placement
that cuts an eye doing obviously the
blood was running the eye but it crosses
multiple muscles where you can get
lifelong damage droopy eye like there's
they stop that fight for a reason I that
they could have stopped it around
earlier it's a shame you know but
just glad Corey wanted to be honest yeah
glad he won
uh yeah five night I agree with that
Gregory Rodriguez and uh Connie Savage
Andre feely who I was cheered for got to
win as well he looked phenomenal
now that's interesting how the [ __ ] did
Nick win his bet if Tanner Bowser lost I
think it's the over under thingy Jimmy
like yeah yeah you're right all right
let's take another little break Boston I
will see you next week Thursday Friday
Saturday those shows are almost sold out
we might add shows get your tickets
thickboy.com
I'll tell you what man you'll see me on
my Instagram stories I'm always bike
riding I'm always hiking I'm doing
something and I got to be listening to
something I just don't want to be there
with my thoughts because I'm weird
alright I need something in my ear I'm
listening to podcasts I'm gonna see the
music and a lot of y'all make fun of me
because I just use the wires I I don't
use the the in Bud things I always have
wires and like Oh I thought you made
money why are you using wires still
that's so freaking
2014. let's look at my ears I have a
tortellini on my left side of my ear
because I used to fight man I'm a black
belt Jiu Jitsu and part of the black
belt is you get yours all messed up and
then part of the problem nobody tells
you is you can't wear uh wireless
earbuds because they don't fit and then
my friends at raycon Wireless came along
and they know exactly how to do it man
raycon is the best the best wireless
earbud I've ever used I use it bike
riding I use it in the green room I use
it Non-Stop recon's everyday earbuds
look feel and sound better than ever and
this is where it helps me out they have
the optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit they ain't lying man they're
comfortable they will not budge trust me
I'm on my bike like this all right
raycons give you eight hours of Play
Time a 32 hour battery life Ray Conn's
also they're not gonna charge you the
bank it's not a mortgage payment you
give them at half the price of other
premium audio Brands it's no wonder
raycons everyday earbuds have over 50
000 five-star reviews we got you man go
to buy raycon.com shop today to get 15
off your raycon order that's by raycon
buy
r-a-y-c-o-n.com
schab and you get 15 off buy raycon.com
shop one more read kids then we're going
right back to the program because when
you see me right you're like man this
vocabulary has gotten a lot better
what's he doing he's working on himself
he's reading a lot I'm not much in our
little secret I'm on that Alpha Brain
matter of fact I'm on it as I stare at
this camera right now every time you see
me podcasting stand up just life in
general I'm working out whatever I'm
doing I'm using the Alpha Brain all
right you know those times when you're
you all you can do is focus on the
project at hand the times when you're
most focused right they call that being
in the zone or Flow State what if I told
you you take two little pills I'm
talking about that Alpha Brain from on
it it's the ultimate way to get in the
sorry man to get in the zone a
world-renowned nootropic supplement with
over 1 million bottles sold Alpha Brain
promotes cognitive functions include
memory mental speed and focus I need all
the help I can get kids I got a splash
of CT but thanks to Alpha Brain I'm out
here shooting off sentences like
freaking Elon Musk that's right man it's
Alpha Brain you can help you remember
names who remembers names I'm basically
on a family reunion because my grandma
died I couldn't tell you one name of my
cousins all right but I'll be all hopped
up on Alpha Brain imma read over the
list I'm gonna remember all their names
not hurting anybody's feelings thanks
Alpha Brain thanks on it all right it
helps me think more clearly under stress
and listen my boy Joe Rogan says that he
feels that it helps them form better
sentences when he's talking do you think
Joe Rogan knows a thing or two about
talking you want to be more like Joe
Rogan less like me cool get Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain contains amino acids plant
compounds that promote the brain's
release of Alpha Waves which helps you
with your creativity helps you with the
productivity it gets you in that flow
State baby all right and also if you're
like a little uh a little you know crazy
about caffeine this is caffeine free you
don't need energy drinks you don't need
coffee you need Alpha Brain all right if
you don't like it here's what's dope
on it and myself we're so confident now
for bringing you get your money back try
it out you don't like it say less eat
your money back but you're gonna love it
all right you're gonna love it you can
save 10 off your order by going to
audit.com job all right that's on it.com
schab you get 10 off or you can go to
your local Walmart and pick it up today
so you can either just go online help
your boy out gohanna.com shop or you can
put on your freaking Dockers and your
Crocs in a button-up Polo and go to
Walmart and see the meetings at Walmart
what are you gonna do you go to
audit.com
gets delivered to your door door avoid
all the
Riff Raff you feel me go to anna.com
shop 10 off Alpha Brain you're welcome
uh what else you got you
um you just mentioned Andre feely so he
uh called out the one of the judges
it was competitive but these judges are
I don't [ __ ] know what these judges
are looking at man like I don't know
I mean I thank God they didn't rob me
but dude it's they don't they gotta stop
trying to scare me well one says one and
two you took around one on all the cards
he took round two on all the cards and
the split was because one judge gave him
round three I guess presumably because
of those punches I just I'm just like
okay you
let's talk about it
let's get down to it what is it what is
a more significant threat to finishing a
fight my hand under his throat ready to
strain him or him punching me in the top
of my forehead from two inches away it's
like what and if a judge legitimately
looks at that and says that he was
closer to winning that I should be
judging third round
[ __ ] that guy yeah like I don't know
assistant I wish I had a more eloquent
thing to say but you don't if you think
that punches from from here is a more
legitimate fight-ending threat than a
rear naked choke from the back
you don't know what you're doing yeah I
agree with him 100 the problem is that
there's no
there's no repercussions for these
judges like he's just like oh my bad
like no man there should be a panel
where and they're not going to beat them
up or you know when I say beat them up
verbally they're not going to destroy
them but all three judges I think in MMA
boxing different animal it's old as a
[ __ ] dinosaurs you know boxing is
Mummy judging and it's so corrupt We're
Not Gonna that's never gonna happen but
UFC how dope would it be as if after the
big fights and there's controversy with
the judging you're allowed they put like
four to five media members who the UFC
can choose which they do anyway they
choose and they ask questions like why
did you do this explain this and then
you go then to his point well you're
judging based off the punch at the top
of the head but the rear naked choke you
don't see that being more detrimental or
finishing the fight more important so
you'd give the other guy around and then
they explain themselves because what if
this judge Chris Lee and I'm being super
super friendly here what if he gave you
some sort of explanation that made sense
and like okay can see that he sure
thought he can't but if he did I think
it would go a long way with the fans and
the fighters you know yeah but they
never had they're just like nope I had
that guy winning like how the [ __ ] did
you come up with that and we just let it
slide let it slide they could cost 100
feet like uh you know a huge opportunity
man these guys get half their pays when
these shitty judges just shoot from the
hip and don't know what they're watching
do you think she goes oh that's judging
going to the hands of the score card
like what the guy I'm in the toughest
biggest league in the world and I I
can't depend on judges nope sorry don't
leave in the hands of the judges like
trust me I'm trying to [ __ ] fish him
it just so happens these guys are pretty
[ __ ] good I'm fighting it it's it's
to me it's the biggest biggest
uh blind spot the UFC has not to do
something about it because they have the
power to there's you know they're
putting out other fires I guess
it is weird how there's no
yeah there's no consequences for the
judges not sucks yeah ever
all right um on that same card Aspen lad
she missed weight again so she couldn't
have her fight with Sarah McMahon this
is our fourth time overall but third
time in the UFC and you said the one
thing that UFC hates the most is missing
weight unless your homicide and this is
a conspiracy with this
unless that case yeah unless they're in
on it and you're fine yeah
yeah she's like they're probably gonna
cut her yeah I would imagine yeah yeah
you keep missing what they they they
it's frowned upon usually unless again
unless you're harmed.net
just adds to my theory right it just
adds to it and Dana came out in the
thing and said uh you know but anyone
who thinks Hamza had a bad week is out
of their mind he had a great week and
this is a guy that I want you guys to go
back and look and see if a fighter has
missed weight and Dana has given any of
them praise ever in the history of a
fire missing weight explain that that's
all I'm saying
that's all I'm saying that's like JFK
getting shot and then the the uh the CIA
being like I mean it happens all the
time man it's not a big deal like no
it's never happened what do you what do
you mean that's insane like oh you're in
on it okay that makes sense
you know that makes sense
go ahead
you know we don't have to keep going
over it I don't even dine on this hill
uh you know I'm at dinosaur that was a
conspiracy it's fun to talk about and I
could definitely see it being some sort
of conspiracy I definitely think there's
something to it and I think the other
problem I have where I get caught up on
just doubling down on my conspiracy is
if you go back over time when he talked
about the commission they would never
let a guy over 10 pounds fight anybody
knows the commission we've done it
before you've done it before and there's
no problem the commission
it's happened before what are you
talking about you know so if there
weren't these these hiccups that he has
to explain why it wasn't a conspiracy
the problem is that like there's
multiple multiple lies and again I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] Nate one
wrote off into the sunset thank God
that's what I wanted homs that's all
good his star's never been bigger he's
now The Dark Knight of the you know the
Joker of the UFC all good everyone's all
everyone got composite all good I don't
give a [ __ ] she don't call me [ __ ]
dummy don't call Pat milkshake [ __ ]
dummy we're good dude I still don't hate
the guy at all any facet
give me content to talk about bring God
I don't give a [ __ ]
alrighty
uh speaking of rich people here's the
paydays Fork now Canelo and Triple G
yeah my God baby
yes
20 million
six five million payouts
yeah that's boxing that makes sense now
the problem here is so people are going
to see this right and I'm sure in the
comments we're gonna have to comments
but I'm sure in the comments people are
like oh and can you and look at the UFC
Pay
I get it and not I'm not defending if
CPA they could definitely pay guys more
I could get into that if I wanted to but
I won't for a variety of reasons but
with Canelo and uh Triple G
look at the undercard it's trash it's
garbage nobody's making any money those
two are the only and when I say only the
only reason anybody bought this
pay-per-view those other the undercards
maybe their family so let's say you have
a big fan let's say there's 10 of you 10
people about the pay-per-views and
they're just friends and family for
those other guys nobody was buying the
pay-per-view for the undercard that's
the difference to the UFC look at the
UFC there's multiple people there that
are selling that thing that's why the
UFC is a better product better fights
better entertainment value better
matchups better production it costs more
to produce it you know so with Triple G
he also has this built-in audience so
um it makes sense that you got paid that
money people always want to compare box
and MMA it's tough man it's very very
tough
those guys deserve that money
yeah so much money I know a lot of money
you know I do with 45 million
um all right this was pretty big over
the weekend as well Gordon Ryan he
submitted Andre galval
at 80cc
yeah ADC was going on at the same time
is that the video there let me yeah it's
uh wait let's see
they're both like crazy jacked too hell
yeah
[Music]
just such a freak dude
[Music]
I mean he is just a human python
you know submit that dude you know
insane that is
America
that doesn't make you proud to be
American you ain't [ __ ]
Gordon Ryan God damn
Legend dude glad John what a Savage Oh
my God look at that body I know they're
both in that big partied up
what is respect everyone fear no one say
last dude them ABS got dog
all right
Luke Rock holds off on that just who has
become a competition of who has the best
steroids it's actually sad I disagree
but that's professional sports in the
nutshell and also if Gordon Ryan's on
[ __ ] and out uh gal valves on [ __ ] well
then it comes down to technique exactly
all right God he looks handsome bastard
too he's so Jack dude how's he not a
model
um so didn't oh no do you know what uh
Daniel Cormier recently um talked about
Tony Ferguson saying that he's just a
shell of himself and he just he should
retire so Tony Ferguson came back with
this yeah I don't like that and if you
go to Jail's Channel he had a great uh
analogy on this he talks about when uh
Rogan and Callan have that intervention
with me to retire and he said and mean
chill he you know he alludes to this
mean shell are very close we talk all
the time I just talked to him three
times this past week right I love chill
when you're training Partners absolutely
love jail sonen
um
you know he talks about with when it
comes to a lot of this stuff and guys
retiring stuff like that and you know
what DC when DC makes a statement it
carries a lot of weight you're talking
about a guy who Olympic wrestler you
know Strike Force world champion UFC
world champion world champion and light
heavyweight world champion uh
heavyweight you're talking about royalty
in the UFC so when he speaks we should
all listen
the only thing with this is it's tough
because
I don't allude to Danny cormier's uh
conclusion that Tony Ferguson's done
he's a shell of himself
I look at it that 170 is just not the
right weight class for Tony Ferguson I'm
not ready to say he's done get him out
of here ship him off to you know
wherever pfl or wherever I think it's
more of okay so you know he was
preparing for his first fight at 170
because he wanted to try something
different he's really not a 170. Tony's
not a big dude Tony is the ideal body
type and uh I would say personality and
mindset to make 155. he's perfect at 155
also
top eight to ever do that 155 who never
won a title top I'd say top three to
never win a title at 155 like Tony in
his prime
when he was walking this walking this
Earth and didn't [ __ ] up his knee it was
supposed to fight khabib there's
argument he was the best lightweight on
the [ __ ] planet so we have to take it
easy going oh he's a shelve himself
everybody gets older the problem with
Tony and getting older is his style
isn't a style of an older man it's a
style where you need to be explosive and
creative and uh have that longevity and
those that kind of bouncy spring in your
step and that that's the first thing to
go especially in the the lighter
divisions that's why you'll see a lot
more older guys have success I like
heavy weight and heavy weight because
the power is the last thing to leave so
for Tony when I look at his fight and
I've watched it several times now
especially
um you know at 170
uh against Nate Diaz he was undersized
so even though he landed some good shots
at 170 it's kind of like the Connor
thing if you remember the first fight
when Conor fought uh Nate Diaz Connor
line some shot that will put sure as
[ __ ] anyone 45 or down on the planet and
not winning 155 or Nate's a bigger guy
than Connor so they're going to be able
to absorb more of those punches and it
wears you out Landing those punches and
those guys keep coming forward so for
Tony too he's he landed a lot of punches
but you know being the lighter guy
didn't have the same impact that did at
55 then also his one of his number one
tools especially against Nate Diaz and
this is I'm just uh piggybacking off
what Chael pointed out which is a great
example one of Tony's number one weapons
the way he was going to beat Nate Diaz
and I'm not saying anything that any
fighter that's ever fought in Nate Diaz
doesn't know this but they have an issue
with checking light kicks it's really
not their thing they don't work on it
they do what they do and they're very
good at it but the light kick is an area
where you can expose one of the Diaz
brothers
so Tony if you remember throws a kick
early on the first round and you know
his shin bleeding gets [ __ ] up and he
actually injured that leg so he couldn't
feel that kick anymore so if you're the
smaller guy and you'll stay on the
outside and be creative but also use
that kick to just chop Nate down keep
him from coming forward and hopefully
you know as the fight goes on wears ass
out and take away that light completely
so he can't you know use it to spring
forward with the jab and walk forward
when that weapon's gone especially the
smaller guy he kind of [ __ ] man
um so I can see how DC you know he's a
shell of himself if you look back at the
the prime Tony of course dude he's older
and
um
he could have worded it better where it
wasn't so mean a shell of himself Jesus
Christ dude you could have said ah with
Tony style he just needs to go back to
the drawing board and do what works for
him because Nate's adjusted for his age
uh Glover texiera adjusted to it for his
age DC even adjusted to his age so as
you get older you gotta adapt your style
and use the tools that you have to win
these fights so the fights in your favor
even though you're older well for Tony
with his footwork and his crazy crazy
movement explosives and explosiveness as
unconventional style that's not gonna
fare well when you get older it's gonna
be tough so I think Tony just needs to
figure it out right and he he went for
the first time to with a real Camp I'm
not saying to have a real Camp before
just because again you're talking about
top three to never win a tie that
lightweight of all time hands down I'd
love to hear the argument so Tony is a
[ __ ] Savage and still has all that
that knowledge and all that experience
in the UFC he just has to adjust it's
going to take some time now to make
those adjustments against Nate Diaz in a
main event for four for five rounds is
tough man to do on the Fly especially
against the veteran Nate Diaz who has
adapted a style at his age that worked
for him we know what Nate was going to
do we didn't know what Tony was going to
do so for Tony a show of himself is so
it's so Cutthroat and in fighting you do
got to be Cutthroat but I think Tony can
definitely compete at 155 with the top
five guys it's gonna be tough I think
those days are probably done done but
can he compete you know six through 20
absolutely absolutely absolutely
nowadays with a camp he's at you know
he's he's with Jackson's and he's kind
of getting familiar with that and now he
knows all right I'm older so the same
stuff I've been doing the spinning back
that was the the kicks all that [ __ ] you
know maybe when I can throw that as much
but he has a style that he could
Implement to win fights at 155. I
guarantee he can do that so
um you know I I think for him it's just
about it's an ego check it's a humbling
thing on I can't do some of the stuff I
used to do anymore having a different
mindset but you gotta understand
out of all the guys in the FC roster
there's nobody who would literally die
inside that octagon like Tony Ferguson
and he trains that way he trains like
you've never seen man I've TR I've
trained with a guy for years dude at
rain ah you've never seen anything like
it man his tenacity his his cardio is
frightening to be to be honest it's
concerning you're like dude you know
what are you doing we would do practice
right we would it be wrestling practice
or sparring he would go all the rounds
then some all comers it could be a new
guy who just walked in Tony would go
against the elite guys in our gym he
would go 10 Rounds with them and then
we're all exhausted and Tony's put in
more work than we are and Tony's going
with more guys more guys more guys he's
doing 15 20 rounds and I'm and I'm
changing I'm showered up I come back out
he's not only has he done sparring but
now he's wrestling he goes another hour
of wrestling you've a guy's never been
never you saw this always hit him up
never fail a test
I bet I bet he barely takes a [ __ ]
protein powder
so for those people that when they you
see these freaks with their cardio and
their mindset and you can't comprehend
and go oh steroids
that that that you're just you can't
comprehend that somebody is that
mentally Savage that somebody is willing
to go to the edge of the [ __ ] Earth
to win a fight I don't I'm telling you I
don't know a guy in the UFC who's
willing to touch the death doorstep than
Tony Ferguson all he has to do is adjust
his fighting style and make it
age-appropriate like Nate Diaz has done
and go back to a 55 stick with Jackson's
camp and you're he's gonna rip off some
wins man if you if the USC would be
just play some ball with 20 freaks in
which they should right because he saved
the [ __ ] card right he saved the card
so you owe it to him look give me my 55
give him a fight that he that's winnable
for him and let him adjust to this new
fighting style Tony is gonna have a
Resurgence I I would bet my last dollar
on it to write him off ago he's a shell
of himself come on let's it's a little
much man and now
I'm sure time will tell that oh Daniel
Daniel Cormier being on the side of
caution is always the best way to go
with Fighters when it comes to Tony
Ferguson he's there's everybody in the
UFC if anybody who's ever fought in FC
anybody who's ever risked their their
ego their their status their whatever it
is in the UFC all of them are one
percenters
I'm telling you [ __ ] I've seen it
firsthand Tony Ferguson take anybody
who's ever fought in the UFC he's the
0.01 percenter there's nobody like Tony
Ferguson with his mentality in his work
ethic
and if you if you if and that's the
biggest
biggest advantage that Tony has so if if
he can channel that into the right
direction that works for him in his age
I'm towning man he's not a guy to write
off he's just not he's not it's not fair
to do it to him he shouldn't be at 170
should be at 55 you shouldn't be
fighting the top four guys every fight
fight in fight out he should be fighting
appropriate opponents and fighting at
his appropriate age and his style and
I'm telling you I bet he rips off
[ __ ] five wins in a row and then
you're doing him a top guy and
everyone's gonna be cheering for him you
know you the UFC just has to play ball
with him a little bit and they should
they absolutely should but I'm I'm
[ __ ] Tony man you don't know a more
Savage professional athlete than Tony
Ferguson they talk about the Kobe
mentality
fine and dandy if he's playing [ __ ]
basketball right he's shooting
basketball there's no consequence of
shooting basketball there's the Kobe
mentality which we all we allude that to
everything everybody that's a Kobe
mentality Usman has a Kobe mentality I
get all that the Tony Ferguson mentality
nobody else can do like I'm [ __ ]
telling you man maybe there's some
special forces guys in delta or Navy
Seals with that mentality there's no
other professional athlete active that
has Tony Ferguson's mentality
all he has to do is adjust to his
athleticism and his age and you've got a
[ __ ] special person on your hands you
know he's a he already has a built-in
fan base he already has that don't give
a [ __ ] Nate Diaz fan base right people
love Tony Ferguson the Nate Diaz was
like dude I'm glad I'm fighting one of
the real ones we're we're all aware of
what 20 represents
all you got to do is and again I have
more of a connection to it because I've
seen him not in front of the cameras not
in front of the Octagon I've seen him
training the amount of training he puts
in talk to Cheeto about it he's like
dude that guy will get done training
he'll Run 10 miles
you I'm telling you you've never seen
anything like it so all he has to do
is a Justice fighting style that's age
appropriate and figure out what worked
for him and remember Tony can wrestle
his ass off he just decides not to do it
but at his age he should probably do a
little more to win some rounds you know
you don't have to be that you know
killer finisher now you can use your
wrestling and then you use your Jutsu
Tony on top Tony takes you down and
everybody wants to get to their feet
there I'm looking at 155 right now
maybe Charles Oliveira outside that
there ain't a guy better more dangerous
in transition than 21st Tony Ferguson in
the UFC at any age
so there's there's some if if I'm his
coach I'm looking at this [ __ ] bullet
points here all right well his cardio
second to [ __ ] none his mentality
we've never seen his his uh Jiu Jitsu
his ability to finish it during
transition there's nobody like it the
spinning elbows the weird [ __ ] all right
get rid of that he can do a little bit
of it if you're up on the rounds but
let's not focus on that anymore but
again that's what makes Tony special so
there if his coaching and Jackson's the
best at this you we just gotta Channel
him in the right direction and I would
bet my last I'm telling you Tony's not a
guy you want to bet against and DC is
actually doing Tony a favor here you're
putting a fire under a guy that does not
need motivation
and now everybody's writing them off I
again I know I keep saying I feel sorry
whoever whoever has to fight Tony
Ferguson that's you're gonna have a real
[ __ ] problem on your hands if he can
Channel
the appropriate game plan for his age
I'm telling he's gonna rip off five
[ __ ] wins I would I would bet my
[ __ ] last dollar if the UFC is
willing to play ball with him at 55.
they give him the appropriate match up
next I wouldn't bet my [ __ ] house on
21st that's what you're dealing with
shout out to Tony That's Tony Ferguson
Tony University anything like you man I
heard his training was pretty crazy like
ninja training dude I'm telling you dude
ask Eddie Bravo about it when he was
putting his camps together like who them
you
there was no Rhyme or Reason to it
that's what made him so special nobody
trained like Tony Not only would they
not train as hard and as long as he did
but nobody trained the way he did
never
and so if you can take that and that
worked for him back in the day but now
you put them in Jackson's who have it
dialed down man we enlist all the
champions of the Jacksons they've had
dialed down if you can take that
and funnel it into the right direction
I'm telling you Toby mentality cool and
rest in peace I'm a huge fan of Kobe
Bryant that Kobe thing
ain't [ __ ] compared to the Tony first
mentality you've never seen somebody
like Tony Ferguson in any sport
I don't know Delta Force guys or Navy
SEAL guys I assume there's one of those
outliers like Tony Tony's one of those
guys it's frightening it's frightening
literally frightening
literally I'm telling you dude you've
never it's alarming at a professional
level to see him be an outlier like this
I've seen it firsthand and I won't
mention the names in that room but those
guys
that we train with and we're at the time
we were bigger names than Tony we were
talking like Jesus Christ man shut it
down refuse to and here we get done with
that and I found out he's running 10
miles at midnight
insane
you've never seen anything like it
whatever cam Haines does Tony could do
besides shoot the bow and arrow like him
but when he does those Death Valley run
I bet you I could call Tony up right now
I'm like hey dude uh there's this Death
Valley Race it's gonna be 150 degrees
you want to run it he'd be like yeah I'm
in infinite easy finish it probably do
well probably beat uh some some of the
people that all they do is specialize in
it because mentality he's just built
different dude
he's not built like these other guys
oh you mentioned bow and arrow so just
reminding me of this
this is uh
that's Alex Bahia
is he is his next opponent and Joe Rogan
reposted this
is pretty fun yeah I like that I like
Dan Thomas shout out to dinner he was
the most impressive part is he did in
the Rock shoes you know the most
impressive part is the rock shoes didn't
crumble yeah speaking of the rock shoes
uh Terence McKinney is calling out the
rock about it
I love doing this mechanic too he's a
great fellow Fighters asked where the
rock shoot so just because he put come
on man with a Emoji of you know covering
the face like come on dude it says uh
bloody elbow shut the bloody elbow at
bloody I will put Fighters has to wear
The Rock's shoes but won't get paid for
the new UFC sponsorship uh-uh and then
this is what uh Karen says Chad says Hey
brother if you're a fan of what we do
the deal uh if you're a fan of what we
do make the deal favorable for the ones
modeling your shoe I guess it's not your
fault or your business doing it to us
but show us the love you think you think
you are get in our corn and support us
Iraq if you just took a fraction of what
you made on Jumanji 19 or the [ __ ]
you're shooting next and sent to the
fighters they'd be stoked dude yeah can
you can you just imagine like if I'm a
rock and I have my shoe let's say there
was a thick boy shoe right and I'm sure
Rock's way business I am but even at the
level that that I'm at I don't know a
lot of things going on with my business
until it becomes an issue
um so I'm sure Rock didn't know so I was
like yeah you know they probably came
with hey you know UFC fights you can
wear your shoes and Rock's like oh sick
man
but they don't they don't know the game
and they should have learned from Reebok
Reebok to go winner spots the UFC's
gonna be sick man and all the guys gonna
be stoked about gear were not stoked it
ruined your brand you're [ __ ] have you
heard of Reebok since it's the worst
business Choice they've ever made in
their lives Nate name the last time you
saw somebody wearing Reeboks name the
last time you saw somebody wearing a
Reebok fight kit it literally ruined the
reputation not their fault has nothing
to do with them they just don't know the
game so with the rock dude you got your
tequila that's popping but again I'm the
alley cat version of The Rock right I'm
the poor man's version of The Rock I got
my whiskey I got my merch I got you know
I'm touring he's doing all his [ __ ]
so for the rock dude everything's going
well I'm telling you dude you force and
again it's not your fault you know what
the [ __ ] how the business works but you
force these fighters to wear those
can we bring him up I'm a singer you
force
these fighters to where your [ __ ]
shoes and you're not gonna pay them
I would love
I would love to hear the explanation
where you think that's okay
I think these yeah this one
I'm not mad at them but usually every
Under Armor shoe I saw was just like I
could never I never never no you look
like a [ __ ] tool they might as well
be Sketchers but those they're those are
kind of lady especially the the red ones
with the cement bottoms okay not too bad
and when The Rock first came out with
workout shoes I tried getting them I
tried giving them money
they were legit Have You Ever Seen The
Rocks workout shoes Mark legit they sold
out like this you couldn't get them I
tried get them couldn't get them then I
went on stockx hit up my boys at suplex
for like 500.
and for the rock with his business come
on bubba you you don't need to you don't
need the money whatever the UFC's paying
your business partners to for them to
wear these shoes you don't need that
money like those are [ __ ] dope son I
would I'm gonna buy those they're
actually looking better aren't those
dope I just don't like that freaking
um that's his logo he's a bull man I
know I know Rock the bull you know rock
rock your bull
it didn't make sense
yeah that makes sense
um but they're not bad at all yeah
you're right yeah but if someone just
say hey Rock let me talk real quick hey
those shoes man they're dope right I'm
telling you man the the bad pressure
you're gonna get by whoever made the
deal to force the fighters to wear the
shoes and not get paid it's not worth it
man we got to give these Fighters some
money
and I feel like once Rock cares this
because remember
Rock was an athlete at the University of
Miami
and then also nobody takes more
Advantage than their athletes than WWE
so
he knows the game and he has he has to
have some sympathy towards it now if you
could give back to we guys I'm sure he
would right but that's not his business
but not his business involved with Doc
you don't like part of this dude you
want to be part of this slave driven
business you know damn well you could
help these guys out come on dude I'd be
willing to bet in the next two weeks we
get Fighters are getting compensate for
wearing the rock shoes you know I don't
know a thousand dollars or something
like that I would bet my last dollar
that that comes out
I bet Rock wasn't aware of it
probably not he has so much stuff going
on Casey just sent me this but also the
UFC's like the UFC is also like hey look
kids you get free shoes
look what we did we did a deal where we
get paid and you Market it and you get
free shoes like hey what the [ __ ] in
what world would we want to do that deal
but again
this one this is the problems you see
UFC none of this would ever [ __ ] fly
in any other leak MLB
NFL NBA they sign one of those deals and
let's say the M let's take the NBA which
is the biggest uh kind of sneaker deal
there is right that's the the NBA made a
deal with just Nike so everyone was
forced to wear Nike on that floor they
getting paid because you got to go
through the NBA Basketball Players
Association who represents the players
who control the league the union yeah
if the MLB same thing MLB split 50 50 I
think most are 50 50. do you see is just
dabbling down and [ __ ] the fighters
over it in 2022 and now there's the
internet and then there's [ __ ] like
me
where you call me a [ __ ] dummy well
now I gotta light you up a little bit
you know so you're gonna Force fighters
to wear shoes and not pay them in what
world are you living in where we're
gonna think this is okay
if I'm the if I'm the fighter don't wear
them why don't you guys this for all
fighters out there why don't you grow a
[ __ ] site and when they give you
those [ __ ] UFC Rock shoes if they
don't come to some sort of agreement
where you get paid set them on fire and
put on your [ __ ] Instagram
post a picture you're wearing some dope
ass other sneakers that aren't Under
Armor let Under Armor know and just so
you guys are aware Under Armor is making
so much money off the Rock and Steph
Curry this is what you're dealing with
you guys are getting zero zero
they just signed Steph Curry to a
billion dollar deal
they have the money to pay you guys but
you have nobody vouching for you
speaking up for you so all you're doing
is getting taken advantage of because
there's not you guys under one agreement
they have to deal with 90 different
[ __ ] managers and nobody can get
together it's like wrangling cats so
when you guys are unorganized you're
dealing with somebody who's very
organized in the UFC you're unorganized
you're getting taken advantage of
so if you want to fight back and get
paid for once in your [ __ ] life if
your name's not Conor McGregor Brock
Lesnar Ronda Rousey when they give you
those shoes all you guys should be
posting on social media and [ __ ] send
them on fire and put hashtag pay the UFC
fighters there's an idea
but you know what's gonna happen you
know what's gonna happen
again I hope the rock realize this is
the worst press he's ever got
besides didn't want to come on Joe
Rogan's show and then literally a minute
later retracting that statement because
he has no backbone but that was bad
press That's whatever we forgot about
that I didn't but this is the second
worst press you've ever got is forcing
fighters to wear your shoes which I
actually don't mind them
but what's going to happen even if the
UFC doesn't
um come to an agreement and pay the
fighters you know what's going to happen
nothing you guys going to take it and
this is just another reason why you need
to have a union there's another reason
that you're you give the UFC an inch
they're taking a [ __ ] mouth they're
just taking advantage of you guys in in
what other league I would love an
example name another League where they
would force you to wear some where they
get compensated and you get [ __ ]
nothing
it's insane
and you see it doesn't even mention it
yeah they're gonna do whatever the
[ __ ] time man it's all good
how does the Rocks people his
Representatives when they're negotiating
the UFC go wait hold on hold on they're
just gonna wear them and Daniels yeah
they have to we forced them to well and
we don't have to pay him not at all just
pay us man oh cool we'll do that
how much is how much you guys gonna take
dude before you finally fight back and
now because of social media you can't
actually do something
but y'all ain't gonna do [ __ ] you can do
nothing
wear those [ __ ] shoes don't get
compensated that's how this goes
and then all the [ __ ] managers they're
like we don't cause a stair man because
he gives a bad match up we're scared or
they're not gonna give us a fight
they're we're in renegotiation for your
third contract man we don't want to die
in this hill everyone's like just cogs
in the machine y'all ain't gonna do [ __ ]
that's how this goes you're gonna wear
those [ __ ] rock shoes you're not
gonna do [ __ ] that's how it goes
cool man I need to complain about it
one or two guys in another car to
complain about it
but guess what you're wearing them
you're even complain about I mean when
all right let me see the snake one yeah
issues
hey
here's the thing though right [ __ ] these
shoes you wearing them you have to put
it back on hey and then put it back on
yeah yeah [ __ ] these shoes you wearing
them
gotta do it yep
um all right so that's interesting
mom Ryan's just retired and now he's
back in the pr not back in but he's with
pfl who you know the owner yeah World
Series yeah yeah
guys on Earth I'm coming home where I
started I want to thank the legendary
stefo and pfl get ready for some
firework all right well
mm-hmm
all right
I mean he did you know became world
champion World Series that's where he
made his bone so I get it
I assume it's like one or two fights
um
um thick one is announced this already
but yeah Calvin kater versus Arnold
Allen in October oh oh I love me some
Calvin kater but there's what if there's
one person I told you guys he's my dark
horse in the featherweight division it's
Arnold Allen his father was a strong man
this dude is undefeated I hate this
fight for Calvin kator it's so tough to
touch it I'm telling you man if you have
to pick if you have to I don't know
about if DraftKings has these odds but
if you can pick the odds for the next
guy to kind of be the threatened
division it's Arnold Allen he's the next
Brit to get a a strap around his waist
Leon Edwards you know got it done
against Kumar Usman Arnold Allen is a
guy who can definitely get it done he is
a [ __ ] Savage
yeah
great fight though so that's October
29th am I in town
let's see I've chosen Calgary on the
27th 28th that's a Saturday I could fly
back and make that
that might be worth it we need some
companions in October we'll talk about
after this all right and another matchup
which is tough for Bryce Mitchell but
Bryce Mitchell's first versus undefeated
evlav somebody's o has got to go yeah
God damn that's a good fight and that's
in November yep
man those are two tasty tasty tough
fights
and we'll just do one more yeah uh let's
see I just thought this picture is
pretty cool this is oh my brother sent
me this I love this [ __ ] thing it's
insane so that's basically Jake Paul and
Logan Paul as kids meeting Anderson
Silva and later on during the press
conference because now Anderson Silva's
gonna box Jake Paul throughout they took
the same picture I think it's funny too
so
um
jail sewn and uh was that uh like
narrated the press conference hosted the
press conference that's so cool and he
so uh I think Ariel helwani was supposed
to and then he couldn't probably because
he's busy with all the stuff he's doing
so the they called Chael to do it I'm
right up the street no big deal
um but then uh so Chao flew down and did
it and I hit up Chad I'm like dude he
came to LA and didn't check in with me
how dare he's like dude I'm off to the
next press conference but he told me
this hopefully I'm not speaking on turn
he goes you know I you know Anderson
Silva Jake Paul I figured you know I
don't know people gonna dig it he's like
dude this press conference they
announced like uh two days before he's
like there's people waiting outside that
thing was packed man he's like there's
definitely interest for it he's a thing
was packed pack-backed so
um when I talked to Jake too Jake was
calling me because he loves how I lit up
Dana
he's just talking about it yeah Bubba
I'm I'm being friendly this is the kid
friendly version
so uh yeah Jake Paul Anderson
Silverman's the real deal there and
hopefully if Jake were to knock out
Anderson Silva which is a big if you
know knock out Anderson but if you're
gonna do that you got to give the kids
some [ __ ] respect I know he's not
your prototypical boxer but dude
Anderson Silva he used to be Julio
Chavez Jr's son
Anderson Silva asked your son why he
never goes to his barbecue chill ass in
ass in Brazil and says no here in Brazil
a lot of people try to kill you let me
see that yeah this is so funny yes jail
talks so much [ __ ] brother yeah
okay okay here's the thing I didn't
think it was a sincere offer if I knew I
was really invited and that I didn't
know if your wine forgave me it was it
was a whole thing the real answer please
in Brazil no here in Brazil a lot of
people trying to kill you
no no no do it here in Brazil they try
and kill you yeah oh that's funny yeah
he's the original [ __ ] talker man and
Kobe said oh then Kobe said hold my bear
I'm gonna use that same [ __ ]
Mastermind marketing yeah I think y'all
helped a lot of people as far as how to
do that thing
well him and Colby are very close yeah
very close came from the same area is
that it that's pretty much a slow week
for fighting you fight fans you get kind
of a weekend off when you got a Bellator
whenever Benson Henderson fighting you
never matter yet you'll Romero fighting
Melvin man of which is interesting be
fun yeah it's a Friday Friday card as
well yo it's on Friday yeah
uh yeah I try and watch this are you
being Denver for my grandma's funeral oh
yeah sorry what can you do uh not this
week but next week we are almost sold
out we're about to add some shows Boston
tripping up to Boston baby Boston
Massachusetts last Boston September 29th
through October 1st then October 13th
through the 15th San Jose San Jose
Improv and then one of my favorite clubs
ever the the owner of the club's one of
my favorite humans on this Earth because
his uh brother was offensive coordinated
for Alabama so all we do is talk
football in the Green Room which is rare
these days but you have uh Wise Guys
Salt Lake City baby Utah Salt Lake City
and then Calgary that show on the 27th
is damn near sold out so we're Adam and
Sean's 28th on that Friday that's at the
Rooftop in Calgary Canada at the rooftop
downtown Calgary come get you some
Calgary but uh Boston you're up next
next week Thursday Friday Saturday last
Boston very few tickets are left we
might have to add some shows get get
your tickets right now that [ __ ] will
sell out Thursday Friday Saturday one
show Thursday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday as of now we'll see if we're
gonna add shows but get your tickets
right now Boston September 29th to
October 1st tickets at thick boy.com uh
the tie-dye thick Boy shirt you see me
rocking we have this in tight I tease
sweatshirts
um and shorts that's dropping pretty
soon here too so stay tuned and that
will be on thick boy.com the next uh
week or so all right all right kids your
boy has to go to Denver for a funeral
and then next week I'm in Boston so hope
you enjoyed the fights we have some
great food trucks coming up Thanks for
liking subscribing I launched my all new
uh comedy channel YouTube so all the
Green Room diary bits which I write the
minute I get in the green room I ride a
bit for that City or whatever's going on
and then I do it on Thursday punch it up
for Friday and then Saturday we record
my blast out that Monday for you guys
um and that's just a
fun thing to do so all that content with
Gringo poppy clips that have never been
seen
um stuff from Comedy Central show time
Green Room Diaries on the road all
that's at Brendan Shop YouTube that's
where all the comedies can be flowing
through so get you some man go like
subscribe please and uh every thousand
um subscribers we're picking one lucky
fan and I will send you a signed Funko
Pop uh action figure I guess we'll call
it is about to say doll but sounds gay
uh action figure brand shop thick boy
Funko action figure we only have 30 of
them so I'll sign it ship it out to you
guys I think we just got over a thousand
like 1200 on that uh new comedy YouTube
page which we just launched so go get
you some right now uh the Thousand we're
gonna pick someone rambly and we will
send you the Funko action figure signed
and all that stuff all right uh anything
you need whiskey tiger thick whiskey
available at thinkboy.com all that stuff
get you some uh thank you guys for
liking subscribing watching I love you
guys stay safe till next time I'm out